make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and in
this video we're gonna be a little bit
dangerous we are going to cover Marvel
1602 or at least part one Marvel 1602 is
one of these really interesting stories
because this it was written by Neil
Gaiman but it's not like Sandman it's
starkly different it's amazing but it's
different in a lot of different ways
right so and we'll find out how
different it is right so what this does
is this initially picks up basically
with Queen Elizabeth right having a
meeting with her guy Sir Nicholas Fury
now the cool thing about this is that
Nick Fury is one of these characters in
comics and Marvel Comics where his role
just never really changes he's always
the same guy right like old-school white
guy Nick Fury was always the same guy he
was mysterious he was duplicitous but he
was basically the intelligence guy he
knew everything that was going on before
everybody else did but nonetheless what
you have here is you have basically
Nicholas Fury meeting with a queen and
dumping a bit of information and then in
turn we end up having Stephen strange
who joins in now Stephen strange showing
up here is not the traditional master of
the mystic arts that we would expect
right that's not really what this is
Stephen strange is more akin to an
alchemist he's the guy that's basically
running up on the Queen who's sick and
feeding her like some kind of soup
composed of like some weird plants
somewhere and barley that's basically
what he has that's more or less what
this guy is now with Doctor Strange
showing up here he's basically told by
the Queen tell Nicholas fury what you've
heard and what Doctor Strange seems to
reveal here is there some kind of a plot
or some kind of scenario brewing based
out of Jerusalem and they don't really
know exactly what it is that's going on
whatever this particular object or
artifact is if it fell into the wrong
hands it could be the undoing of England
right he could bring everything crashing
down and that's really where this this
story gets kind of interesting because
it all basically takes place in England
itself and so what it does you know we
end up having Stephen strange and make
fury who kind of go out and have a bit
of a conversation we end up switching to
basically this this high tower the
powers of Inquisition in Spain and we
basically have this guy who's all
chained up and what he talks about is
how individuals had been burned at the
stake he's heard it happen different
things like that and he's not really
being allowed to be killed but he
doesn't really even know why he's here
in the first place all this guy knows is
that he's basically just been chained up
here and then they've come and asked him
questions occasionally but they ask him
more like a friend right so it's not
like they're using hot pokers you know
or they're using like an Iron Maiden or
anything like that to get information
out of this guy instead it's just kind
of like I know why they had me here but
damn really given any indication of what
they want and what we end up finding out
is this is Warren Worthington this is
angel and he's here of course with his
angel's wings and so the indication is
that somewhere along the line somebody
found out who he was and then he's been
brought here to the Inquisition now the
other sad thing about this is it kind of
makes this comment right the next time
he sees the sees the sky he can't fly
you know because he's chained up the
next time he sees the sky it'll be when
he's ashes and his ashes are basically
kind of going off into the end of the
air and it's a sad thing to hear it's a
sad thing to see but what it does here
is it basically switches over to a
couple things going on right so we
basically pick up in a place called the
Morshead which is a tavern in
Westminster and you've got a bard there
a guy basically playing music and then
you've got this kid who's sitting at the
bar and kind of messing around with a
spider now the bard himself as he goes
through and he starts playing songs for
people about the Fantastic Four which
are really kind of given to us or the
indication is that they were basically
explorers you know in the sense they
boarded a vessel and then went off into
wherever the world might take them never
to return so the large assumption seems
to be that they're dead it's very
superstitious which is how it was back
then but we end up of course finding out
that this young kid is named Peter now
we of course know this is essentially
the stand-in for Peter Parker but he's
taken by Nick Fury and then bait and
basically brought to kind of you know
have a conversation of sorts right he's
more or less his young tutor and this
bard where he's kind of dismissed and he
really seems to be somewhat goofy
somewhat silly we end up finding out
this bard is basically daredevil and so
showing up here in this dark room as we
know Matt Murdock cannot actually see
right he other senses which have been
enhanced as a result of his his loss of
vision in order to compensate and so
what this does is is where Matt Murdock
shows up and is like who the heck is
this kid basically Nick Fury's like this
kid is essentially my new assistant
anything you're gonna say in front of me
you can say in front of him seemingly
he's being groomed to replace Nick Fury
as part of the intelligence arm of
England and so what Matt Murdock
basically says is Stephen strange was
right there's word that there's
something coming out of the Jerusalem
right and it's coming this way that
almost all the kingdoms out there right
like the Spanish and the Russians the
whole nine yards they want this right
Count von doom and Latveria
they want this artifact what this
artifact is I don't know but they want
it and so the response of me furious
then you've got ten days to get to
Jerusalem and find out what this is and
then in turn report back to me and so
after receiving payment in the form of a
diamond we in turn basically switch over
to Doctor Strange and Doctor Strange of
course is basically kind of going
through one of his trances more or less
again you know he's kind of invoking the
mystic arts to a degree but
nowhere near grand and scale instead it
almost kind of seemed supernatural in
terms of how it works but what he does
is he gets these vision right he
basically starts saying a series of
things and clears job is to basically
report on what it is that that Stephen
strange is saying because he doesn't
know what he's saying right he's in a
trance he's seeing things and they're
repeating them back and he may not
remember them Rio exactly as he saw them
right so she's there is kind of like a
sort of backup right and so what this
does is it basically shows that there is
a a ship called the Virginia maid and it
basically you know seems to belong to a
young girl along with what looks like a
Native American he's pale never seen him
Native American that pale before but uh
but it's a Native American you know and
then of course he also transitions to
Warren Worthington or to angel inside
the tower the Steven strange can
actually see the various ghosts of
people who have been burned at the stake
like he ends up transitioning to the
Inquisition tower in Spain and the new
courts have a woman who's clothed in red
along with an old guy and this woman can
see Stephen strange where she becomes
aware of him and then banishes him away
given the color it largely seems to be
won and Maxima but basically Stephen
kind of gets these glimpses of things
that are going on in the world at the
moment none of which really seem to
provide any real insight into what it is
is actually going on with regards to
this artifact to this item coming out of
Jerusalem and so from there we actually
switch over to the Inquisition and we
basically pick up with a guy who by all
standards of measurement seems to be
Magneto accompanied by Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver and it's kind of one of
these things where they're essentially
working on the idea of bringing King
James into power right King James of
Scotland and the reason why this matters
is because what it does is it seems to
allow the Inquisitor to be positioned in
a place where he can have a level of
power much higher than what he is right
now so he's just literally trying to
move above his station but he also seems
to kind of have a vendetta against which
breeds what if you guys are reading
Excalibur at the moment you know exactly
what that means it's basically just
mutants and they're referred to as which
breeds here because they just seem to be
people who were invoking witchcraft
right that's kind of the explanation
there and so what happens is Quicksilver
is basically tasked by by the Inquisitor
by Magneto more or less to basically run
to King James and essentially say we
understand that you're trying to access
position or trying to trying to take
over England once the Queen dies we will
make that happen for you we will
basically have the entire kingdom of
England begging for the death of which
breeds and will blame every single
problem on them but what do we do here
is we switch over to the Virginia maid
and we basically had a guy named Rojas
along with along with this this young
girl and now Virginia is the actual name
right so it's just named after
girl and we're not really given a whole
lot of information here outside of the
fact that they're essentially people who
are leaving a particular location
leaving Roanoke basically and showing up
here now the reason why this matters is
because in real world history and 1580
the the Roanoke colonists had just kind
of vanished I'm not gonna swear to the
exact date but the idea behind Roanoke
is that at one point basically
individuals left rono to travel to
England and then come back and that the
entire Roanoke colony had a seemingly
disappear right nobody really knew where
anybody and Roanoke went now as time
progressed and I don't know exactly the
exact history of it but they referred to
what we're known as like blue-eyed
Native Americans and so assume that they
were basically either inducted into the
local Native American tribes or just
outright massacre it's not super super
important here just kind of give you a
little bit of context the whole Roanoke
incident didn't happen by that doesn't
does not seem to have been the case and
and essentially like she did this girl
was basically sent away we along with
Rojas or at least sit here for a
particular purpose although again we
don't know exactly what that purpose is
and so what we end up doing here is
getting a little bit of information a
little bit of factual explanation of
what's going on and so far as you have
Peter who basically starts talking to
Nick Fury asking some questions and Nick
Fury says that a lot of this really
seems to stem from Templars Nick Fury
basically kind of explains that at some
point along the line you had Templars
who were operating as essentially guards
of a great treasure and that within a
century they were the most powerful
force seemingly throughout the entirety
of Europe now after a while the Pope and
the King at the time basically came
together in order to bring down the
template for the King of France and the
Pope came together to essentially rid
their forces and for the most part the
Templars just scattered right like there
were some who stayed in Jerusalem in
order to basically just stay hidden
right they believed that it was easier
to hide in plain sight there were some
who fled the entirety of Jerusalem and
just took off to various locations some
of which were known and some of which
were unknown but no matter what it was
what the history dictates what we know
is that this secret has been well kept
right nobody knows what this treasure is
nobody knows what this artifact is but
seemingly everybody wants to get their
hand on and it seems to to quietly be
moved from one location to the next to
ensure that nobody discovers this
location and that if they happen to
nobody can actually get their hands on
it and so the other reason why Nick Fury
had brought Peter to this location is
because Nick Fury's spies that basically
told him there's people coming out for
you to kill you and so of course you
basically have what looks like vulture
flying down out of nowhere and then
attacking Nick Fury trying to
assassinate him who's protected with
leather and
and then in turn like this vulture guys
basically taken prisoner and that's
basically it and so from there we switch
over to Angel preparing to be burned at
the stake and for the most part he seems
to have made peace with this right he
seems to have made peace with his death
and what it does is it basically allows
him to just kind of understand that hey
this is just the way things go like it
sucks that I'm gonna be burned alive
here right I mean he's not happy about
it like yeah man everybody's got to go
sometime that's not really the stance
but fortunately for him he's saved
because there are people here who are
watching the whole thing unfold one of
them uses their powers to freeze the
torch itself the other one basically
destroys the bonds for Angel only for us
to learn this is Iceman in Cyclops they
literally free this guy attack the
guards right like like Bobby Drake puts
on all this ice in order to block
everybody from getting in there Cyclops
blows a hole in wall and then they bail
right there just immediately out they
take off out of that place and that's
essentially it and so from here you
switch over to angel basically on this
ship you know with Cyclops and and so on
but essentially the questions ask what
am I doing here what's the whole idea
behind this and the response of Cyclops
and everybody is we have a safe haven
right we have a place that we refer to
as the schoolhouse right we also call it
a sanctuary but it's a place where those
like us can travel to in order to learn
how to use our powers and in order to be
safe right it's basically the Xavier
school for gifted youngsters is really
all it is now the funny thing about this
and this was actually a genius move by
by by Neil Gaiman to kind of throw
things off or make them seem a little
more interesting is that John Gray is
not actually John Gray because when I
originally read this I was like John
Gray like this the father of Jean right
like why is he so young in reality it is
Jean right just kind of masquerading as
as a guy by the name of John and so what
this does is it switches over actually
to the the Xavier school itself right
Nick Fury basically showing up here and
when he arrives of course he's met by
beast but it's one of these things where
he kind of muses about the idea that
despite the way he looked but he always
had this sort of high level of
intelligence and that never but nobody
ever really gave him a shot to really
see what his intelligence was but back
then during that sort of primitive time
nobody really cared why he was just how
you looked and then from there they
would decide whether or not you were
worth anything right so it was kind of
bonkers you know in terms of how that
goes down but with beasts bringing out
Charles Xavier you of course have Nick
Fury who basically fires up a pipe with
weed right because I like literally
Professor Xavier is like a noxious weed
Nicholas put it out it fouls the air in
blackens the law
and it's like so basically Nick Fury
smoking weed right that's really what
seemed to be going on
but when Xavier comes out in the two of
them start talking Nick Fury basically
starts saying look there's an important
thing that you have to be aware of here
the Inquisition is on your trail like
despite the fact that they might hate
King James they hate you more and
they're basically looking for any means
to get rid of you right so the enemy of
my enemy is my friend and it's
essentially saying like the fact that
you guys basically broke out angel the
way that you did makes them hate you
even more and so now all you've done is
engender more and more hatred against
you now it's not like Nick Fury's
approaching this from the perspective of
like you really shouldn't have done that
you know it's like you did what you had
to do right you did what you thought was
the right call you know just know that
yes there are consequences for these
kinds of things you know and so
basically Xavier starts to realize their
time of safety is coming to an end
there's only so much they can do and
Xavier more or less seemed to see this
coming and so what he did is he
essentially kind of created the x-men
more or less and it is the original
roster right angel and Cyclops beast
Iceman and Jean Grey of course in this
Marvel 1602 era but that was a whole
idea from it right to basically create a
kind of safeguard to ensure the
protection of themselves and various
other you know mutants out there who may
be sought after by the Inquisition from
here what it does is it sort of breaks
away from that for a second and it
really kind of has Xavier almost kind of
a DAF there's not really a militant
attitude but to basically say this has
been a symbol for the purpose of
protection like we don't go out seeking
fights but we can't protect ourselves
and if what the grand Inquisition is
looking for is to pick a fight well then
they pick the right place because we'll
give them all the fight they can handle
it's one of these things where he's just
not naive is is really what it comes
down to and so jumping over to to London
with the arrival of The Virginian made
with Rojas and with Virginia herself you
basically have you know Peter who kind
of appears out of nowhere and it's like
hey he basically tries to knock on the
door or tries to reach for the door
Rojas base is like grab his hand you
know and that's when Virginia responds
and it's got like hey like let him go
let's find out what it is that he has to
say and in a lot of ways Rojas is just
this super protective bodyguard and so
Peter essentially says look the Queen
you know we'll see you now right like
she summons your presence while she's
here to see whatever it is that you have
to talk about or anything along those
lines and Rojas is kind of okay that I'm
coming the other part of this is that
when we jump over to air devil but of
course he comes across Black Widow the
Black Widow and he seemed to have a kind
of relationship or some sort of history
together
and it's one of these things worse like
look I get you're here on behalf of Nick
Fury the carriage is here it
take you to where you need to go but we
also get this sort of origin for
daredevil you know with the origin of we
get you know we're black we don't ask
the question how was it that you lost
your eyesight all we really get here is
that Matt Murdock himself was just a
curious child right he almost kind of
tributes it to God and says like it was
it was the choice of God or or or
something like that well you know as an
act of him but whatever it was that Matt
Murdock was always kind of curious right
and so we ended up kind of down in this
cave and saw this sort of green ooze
right and when he went to go basically
touch it and then you know he seemed to
put it in his mouth
it basically infected his body and left
him blind now why you're gonna put a
green ooze into your mouth I don't
really know but nonetheless this
basically left him completely and
totally blind right and he's been that
way ever since I saw where his mom tried
to teach him as best she could where he
had had a lot of tutors to tried to help
him you know kind of recover from his
blindness or at least navigate as time
progressed he became exceedingly capable
in what it was that his function was
right to basically serve a goal to
function within the world itself but
then also basically came to work for
Nick Fury and so what you get here are a
lot of fast tracked events happening at
the same time and that's kind of the
crazy that's the craziest thing about
1602
right like you'll get like a whole
plethora of what's going on in like one
particular part of the world on one page
and then like in the next page it'll be
a whole plethora there's so much
dialogue and so much that happens in
this story it's kind of nuts you
basically end up picking up with Victor
Von Doom I just kind of musing at the
idea that he's seeking after this
treasure as well whatever this treasure
happens to be for for Jerusalem you've
got Doctor Strange who after seeing all
these various you know incidents in
these various scenarios decides to go to
the palace he doesn't know why but he
feels like you should all this is kind
of converging into a particular location
but everything is kind of coming
together all at one time not only that
after you had Pietro you know
Quicksilver meeting with the King of
Scotland King James is welcome to the
idea of the Inquisition basically
helping him get a foothold in England
after the fall of the Queen of England
so we can essentially seize power of
this place and so where of course he
ends up coming back explaining
everything to you now you know more or
less the question of Wanda is why is it
that if we have powers we have these
abilities that you know we don't know
they're not a gift from God right why do
we assume that the devil's work and the
response by Dido is because on the grand
inquisitor and I say that it is all
right like that's the case and again
that's how things work nobody really
knew exactly what was going on right
there's no definitive answers that is
God's work they just assume that it is
why they assume their own righteousness
because they fight on behalf of God
therefore everything they do is
inherently righteous because they're
like God is inherently righteous I am a
servant of God therefore everything I do
is righteous that was a kind of argument
that you saw created back then and so
because of that what we end up having of
course is of course the the kind of
coming together of the x-men the
traditional x-men team Xavier actually
calling on Nick Fury and saying hey
we're also gonna need your help here
right like we're gonna need you on our
side and Nick Fury actually takes out a
picture and shows it to Xavier and it's
like I need to know where this guy came
from or who he's serving whoever this
assassin was it tries to kill me and
Xavier responses I don't know right this
guy's mind is clouded with anger over
the fact that he failed to kill you it's
the only thing that fills his mind the
only thought he has that's all he wants
to do right he's there's also like two
other of these assassins out there one
is designed to assassinate the this this
young girl who came there and the third
one is to take out the Queen all this
really seems to be based on the idea of
taking out the Queen and then seemingly
securing the role of King James in
England itself right and so over here we
jump to the kingdom of the Quinn or the
court of the Queen and this is where we
kind of start to get a few answers
button things suddenly go awry right the
question most likely question is why is
this girl here in the first place now
she arrives here and basically says like
my father brings you this map of the
Colony of Roanoke to show you what we've
built to show you what we've done that
your your money has not been in vain
right we didn't just take it and run
we're actually doing stuff make it moves
right we got some things going on but
when she also asked the question about
Rojas this is when we start to get an
actual answer here that yes most Native
Americans had black hair and there's
even a little bit racist in the sense of
like red skin but the response of
Virginia is yes but this guy's different
right and and and my father says this is
proof that the Welsh must have visited
the new world long before the Spanish
but there's very little of them left
behind right as well seems like Rojas is
the only basically white blond-haired
Native American that's out there and so
it's kind of interesting cuz a queen of
my samba dance for a second and and the
responsible houses know I exist to
protect this girl I just protect
Virginia I don't engage in those kinds
of things and so when we get to the
moment we would normally get an
explanation of what's actually happening
here then suddenly this assassin jumps
in and basically ends up grabbing
Virginia and then flying away now Rojas
responds by grabbing a shield and
throwing it at the guy and then in turn
as soon as this guy basically starts to
make it up suddenly Virginia vanishes
well she's nowhere to be seen this guy
comes crashing back down he's got a
massive scratch on his face and when the
question is where in heck is Virginia we
end up seeing Virginia on top of this
tower more or less and she's a hawk
Virginia looks like she has the ability
to transform into animals what happened
he said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here two
comments explained to make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later Bruce
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]